Ros 17. Ros 17. This is what it was all about right from the
very beginning. This is what it was about for this guy. Oh, this
is so embarrassing.
Oh, this needs to be documented. Make sure you archive this stream.
This needs to be documented. This is the weirdest, grossest I've
ever seen. Destiny so upset about this. He's doxing people. That
makes him the real victim. Oh my god. Pisco wouldn't EVEN SAY
THAT DESTINY'S NOT a He's totally starf brain. We have to destroy
him.
>> Who is Pisco talking to? I believe he's talking to the
usurp guy. Hold on. Usurp the chef. He's talking to this guy.
You remember the guy who did the video where he's like throwing
things into his mouth while talking to Hassan? >> Hey son,
how you doing?
I'm happy I was finally able to wake you out of your slump cuz
for a while you had your pants on and you were just too afraid
to have any conversations with people that disagree with you.
But I noticed at the beginning of your stream today you said
you kind of wanted to switch that up and maybe have some conversations
with some of these people. And since well since I triggered the
ever loving [__] out of you today, I'll throw my
hat in a ring. >> This guy was trying to shoot on Pisco
and this guy
this guy is talking to Pisco right now. This guy thinks Hassan
is like going to overthrow the government. This guy's one of
the Yeah, this guy's this guy's a big
>> in the first place and presumably but that's true that
to be true but not everybody else not everybody else he's talking
about the broader audience the people that don't know >> but
the specific
>> the epste
aspect of it raises other concerns regarding the unhingedness
of proposing that hypothetical >> that isn't shown by >> wouldn't
it have been better like Hassan or JD Vance
It shows you you think Hassan is worse than Jeffrey Epstein.
THAT'S WHAT IT SHOWS YOU. >> THAT'S WHAT IT SHOWS YOU.
>> What is you did when you said I over
tell me what is Jeffrey Epstein's policy platform.
>> Dude, [laughter] you don't need That's a fair question,
isn't it? Isn't that relevant to the analysis?
I don't know anything about Jeffrey Epstein's
Would he push for a public option?
Is he a Medicare for all kind of person? I don't know anything
about his politics. The reason why I would not necessarily disqualify
Jeffrey Epstein electorally
is because first we would have to establish if he supports liberal
democracy. Because the whole thing with Hassan is that he doesn't.
And I had people in my own chat last night that thought I was
being ridiculous.
I don't wh how why am I being ridiculous when we're talking about
Hassan [__] These guys talk to millions and millions
and millions of people. They only get 30 or 40 on their live
streams, but you also have to remember that you have their fans
who then take those clips and show it to their friends who might
not be watching those streams. >> That's why I think it's
really good to try to convince people in their audience who might
be on the fence. And I think one way to do that is not to wholesale
ban them from our communities all the time on the basis of their
views. >> Do you think that's irrational for me to take
that position? >> Hey, maybe a way to reach these people
is to convince them. And maybe you don't convince them by doing
a purge of all
>> I can I can see that. I can see that. >> isn't
that like kind of approach that Mach is taking here where he's
like trying to build a bridge with Come on. Let's be honest.
He's building a bridge with Assan. He's being nice to
>> I think he he the fact that he repeated the same questions
three times and got Assan to say three different answers. >> Yeah,
but he was nice and he was nice. He gave him outs. He gave him
outs. He didn't push the way I would have pushed >> you
and you can push. What I'm saying is it's it's not that fate
or shows that I'm a sweeper for tankies that I don't ban them
on the basis of their ideology. One of the reasons why I don't
like to do that is because I like to debate them and I like to
I feel like I own them sometimes and I feel like I do well in
those conversations. >> No, you do. Yeah. The last time
you talk to Ogre Boy, you [__] [__] all
over >> Okay, but like if I just ban them wholesale from
the community, like what does that accomplish? >> And maybe
if I said that you should ban them all. >> Entirely spitebased
position from Destiny. Pisco literally has the same ideas that
Destiny had 3 years ago on how you deal with like extremist political
ideologies or just people you disagree with in general. This
is an entirely spite-based position about Hassan specifically
that Destiny just came up with because he hates that Hassan's
way more popular than him. That's all. Okay. It's totally discordant
with all beliefs he's espoused in the past.
It's such a joke right away at the beginning. I I would I don't
think I actually believe >> you don't debate them in your
chat says >> Sorry. And I talk about I talk about Destiny
because obviously this who's talking to Pisco right now is just
espousing Destiny's beliefs. He doesn't have any of his own.
>> Of course you debate them in the chat. Maybe you don't
tune into the stream enough. I pull out I have this the thing
the system that lets me pull up messages and all the time I yell
left these in the chat. Anyone who's here regularly will see
me do that. No, you don't. Okay, I scroll. No, like I I do that
and um I don't just do it. I do it for mega. >> There was
like a a chatter in your chat. Now again, this is weird, but
like sometimes you think there's like obvious examples where
it's like someone has this. You should probably just ban this.
>> ROS 17. ROS 17. >> And like and that includes
not only just commies and stuff.
>> Bring it up. Bring it up. Bring it up. >> Um the
um >> that's it, right? That's the real
>> why would you think I about that? Why do you keep I
take the viewer appealing to appealing to communist explain why
you're actually here IT >> OH PISCO SHUT UP AND LET THE
GUY TALK he's about to say something he's about to say something
incredibly embarrassing >> from a stream maybe that's engaging
is >> do you think right away or you think of people that
have been slow or that have been over time saying the same things
constantly on liberals >> in your chat
community in your chat of >> I don't think anyone's ever
made a distinction between constant and versus do it one time
>> I've never heard that people come in comes in every
liberals. >> Yeah. And guess what? I have a very um nice
set of conversations that I've had with him where I push back
on it and >> and there could be a world where there could
be a world where in a year and a half your community is 40% >> uh
Yeah, we said this. We said this.
>> I don't I don't even know if that were the case. Are
you going to say that I would be corrupted and I would like >> No,
I know. I would just say it it would just be then another place
where we have a chat room with a liberal streamer base liberal
streamer whose entire audience is is doing infighting all the
time and >> Hey, hey, hey, Pisco, have you thought about
how you should just be loyal to Destiny? Okay, I'm seeing that's
his actual problem. And this guy probably knows to some extent
that he can't just say that. What I actually want to clean up
is not the communists. I like when people own communists. I don't
want the anti- Destiny people here. People who don't like Destiny,
you have to you have to get rid of them. People who don't like
certain streamers, you have to get rid of them. >> We're
fighting and we're trying to like give a home to these arsonists.
>> Like these guys have bed bugs all over them and we're
just letting them in. We're wondering why we're rich. >> Like
Mockler [clears throat] is. >> No, I don't think that.
>> I think Mler did a very good job making Hassan look
>> like like I do with Ogre, right? >> Yeah. But
again, if Mach was I don't think that Hassan would allow cuz
he's not dumb. He wouldn't allow Mockler and his whole crew to
be in his chat.
>> Wait, does Pisco not know that Adam Mockler has seen
like people in his chat? He said to Hassan, I've seen people
in my chat say things like this and I think that's like people
around you like, "Oh, you can't vote for
>> Because he knows even even Hassan knows that if he let
too many bass ass liberals in his chat that it would with him
it would make his projective
against people watch agree with it. >> It's honestly >> I
think that's if you had uh remember like old vulletin like those
old web >> Okay, you just because that is boring to me.
I like people who disagree with me and in fact
>> having only people who agree with me in the chat is
boring and it would inevitably lead to me just like disagreement
libs all the time. But you've got to understand that people are
going to people have a different view at this and it seems that
since these lefties are so good at infiltrating all these communities
all the time that like when you see these communities um are
>> where they're so good at infiltrating all these communities
they're literally just chatters who like Pisco like that Pisco
is a more by the way not all of these people that they refer
to are leftists a lot of them are liberals who just don't like
the community that this guy comes from and so they laugh at that
community but they are just liberals that's why they watch Pisco
because they want their liberal opinions validated. constantly
on liberals all the time and then what happens at the end you
have them in your community
hopefully you can bring them on to our side but then at the end
of the day no matter who the candidate is they're going to vote
third party or
something >> on that view should ban every single person
who's doing harsh critics of me
>> I'm a bas liberal I'm supporting people who are vote
[snorts] for the candidate this is live on the violence so he
should know >> uh no because he has a personal right >> oh
so that obviousates right because of course there's a personal
person [laughter] being yeah no but in terms of justification
in terms of justification you say personal beef obviousates the
uh constant harsh snark criticism of Well, I think he would probably
see that you like have a chatter in your chat a lot called Rose
was 17. And he would probably look at that and be like, "Why
would Pisco my friend not ban somebody like that from my chat
room?" He might take that as like a personal, you know, >> uh,
how about cuz Pisco is trying to say he's not looking into this,
right? Pisco literally said he's not looking into this. Pisco
doesn't want to take a side. If he bans that guy, he has to take
a position. He has to have a reason for banning him. He loses
all predicate for not discussing the case.
>> Attack a strong word. It's like, man, that doesn't feel
good to me. was my friend and this guy also this guy has this
person in their chat. >> Yeah. the position is that I should
take a substantive view on an issue and a set of issues where
I have said for reasons that sometimes even in your to even's
benefit um that and also relate to ethics that um I would necessarily
have to get involved there because I have to take a view on that
right in favor of destiny right >> if you still considered
him a friend >> no stop with this is that the case or not
is is the position that >> dude this it's so gay these
people are so transparent thank you thank you usurp the chef
thank you for coming in and doing this and making it so obvious
what your actual goal is what you're actually doing here. Okay,
you come and you're like, well, if you were still a friend,
>> dude, it's so embarrassing, man. You people are so embarrassing.
>> Well, because I am not venturing into this um subject
that is of the lawsuit and related issues, for good reasons,
for reasons that make sense, for reasons that are honorable and
not dishonorable, for those reasons on others um that >> I'm
necessarily now subject to endless infinite snark even though
I'm a base >> That's No, I don't think that's that's not
what I said, though. Do you want me to ban people? >> You
not covering it is a good thing. You not like I can understand
your position. You're like, listen, it's a messy situation. It's
going on court. And I would imagine maybe, again, I'm not a lawyer.
I don't know if there's any kind of like ethical things that
you shouldn't comment on ongoing cases. If that's a thing that
makes sense. I don't know. But like you guys were friends of
>> people People think I talked to Pisco. This is what
convinces Pisco that that community is not something you want
to engage with. Right. People think I talk to Pisco. I don't
talk to Pisco. I don't have to say anything to Pisco. Just DJ's
interacting with other communities is enough for them to find
that community disgusting. Thank you
>> There's no better starker against DGG than just some
DGER going and joining someone's VC. Thank you so much. >> Together
in New York. Um and you I think you not covering it, you not
going into all the the drama and like reading all the documents
when they come out. I think that's a good thing because >> you
know it's not your place. It's not your business. But at the
same
to see somebody in his chat in your chat called Rose was 17 and
he might look at that be like damn why is he not deleting that
person? That's kind of [__] up. >> I understand
I understand he might think that but the question is like what
do you think I should do? I mean probably just like if any like
in that one scenario probably ban somebody like >> In other
words, take a stance in favor of Destiny in the ongoing issues.
That is what you want them to do. That is >> I think that
is just that is taking a stand at a level that no one would judge
you on. And I think that's a stance that most people would agree
with >> because even if you want to remain neutral having
somebody having like the reason that chat >> stance that
nobody I like to imply that Destiny's a pedophile.
>> Do you believe Dest
is
related to and you're not going to bait me? No, I'm just I don't
think you think that. I do not think you think that. I don't
think you think that you're supposed not going to come.
>> Oh my god. PISCO WOULDN'T EVEN SAY THAT DESTINY'S not
a He's totally dark brain. We have to destroy him, >> right?
Right. So, you understand? Do you understand the issue with me
>> taking a stance in terms of what I comment on? >> It's
so transparent. It's so transparent. This is what it was all
about, right? From the very beginning, this is what it was about
for this guy. It was about, hey, that people say mean things
about Destiny and I really don't like that and I want you. This
guy is saying all the gay, embarrassing, humiliating [__]
that Destiny refused to say cuz he knows it's embarrassing. He
knows it's humiliating to go to another creator and get on your
knees and ask for this, right? He knows how embarrassing it looks.
So, this guy is doing it for him. Wow. And then you delete that
person without commenting. You say, "Hey, I don't let I don't
I don't allow accusations of pedophilia of people being in my
chat without evidence." And I don't like that kind of [__]
My >> for example, was a friend of mine commenting on his
case. I just wish could could is anyone going to ask this guy
wait how old Ros
for example Ethan Klein or Hassan or any other No I'm to get
involved in all these different disputes and and there's new
rule no uncredible accusations >> yeah but I guess maybe
you didn't have the relationship with those people with with
Destiny that's the difference >> yeah so what you're proposing
right what you're proposing is uh empathetic rule a protective
rule that's special a special rule for Destiny correct
>> you don't actually believe what you're saying now do
you >> I do believe what I'm saying. I'm asking you a question.
>> Like you think that this in your mind if you saw somebody
who's like um what if they were making fun of his son, would
you allow that in your chat? >> I if they were making >> like
um Nathan um Destiny bad dad to Nathan, would you allow that
in your >> I don't think that you know any kind of accusation
towards minors. Um I don't know that I would allow. >> Well,
that's what this is. >> No, but that's not an accusation.
That's not an accusation about a minor. That's an accusation
about the stream. >> I think it's I think it's one of the
>> It's also not an accusation about the minor. The minor
was 17. They were a >> Honestly, I think [laughter] that
it is. Wait, this is this is like this is like the probably the
most blacking part of this conversation for me. like in my mind
um because I think it's what I'm asking or what the question
I'm trying to pose is is is is pretty simple like you can not
want to talk about him. You can not want to cover the case. You
can do all that but it's not murky. It's only murky in that like
basically Destiny doesn't like that somebody does that to imply
he's a right I've never called Destiny a for those pictures.
I've said he retained pictures of that person when they were
a minor obviously. So like video of them when they're a minor
and anybody who retains
you know for most of the internet they would call that guy a
okay there's there's a way you work to it but it's not to saying
Destiny was impro like destiny thinking this person was 19 or
whatever and getting nudes from them by the way knew the person
a week had no identifi identity verification at all and still
kept talking to them in a way that totally contradicts the own
advice he's given other creators his own advice he's given other
creat
so many words and you saying like oh Banning that person means
I would be commenting on the case. >> I don't think you
believe that. That would just be someone say, "Hey, I don't like
you accusing former friends of mine. We might not even talk today,
but it if I ban this person, you think if I ban it, will all
of the snarking of there is right?" >> Oh, sorry. You kind
of cut up there. >> Do you believe there's snarking going
>> Snarking of you.
>> Okay. If I ban this, you think? >> Wait. All I
heard is if I ban this person as mic is cutting out. >> Um,
no. Oh, that's not >> But I don't think that you should
ban that and hoping for something and and hope for something
in return. I I would I if I was in your position, I would do
that because that was something I would want to do. I don't expect
anything in >> You're half correct in the following. >> Here's
how you're correct. You're correct in the sense that none of
this is about communism. >> All of that. No, none of it.
Absolutely zero of it. And the reason you're lost, >> No.
No. I'm telling you that none of it has to do. Absolutely none
of it. I'm back out. Testing one, two, three. >> Yeah.
What's Yeah. Sorry. Is that
>> None of it. >> Go. Pisco sees it. He sees through
the matrix. piss goes off the plantation >> [__]
communism and that was aboutism right doesn't have to do about
because people can make reasonable decisions about what is the
best way to influence good people and no sane person no sane
person thinks that I'm turning into a communist that's that's
an insane thing to say even in the area >> I don't think
anyone's even saying that >> then why would I be speaking
for them >> for money
opinions change opinions >> if you think that this the
way to grow an audience is to you know sometimes take stances
you know principally that happen to favor lives and sometimes
take stances that principally happen to favor communist sometimes
or socialist whatever on the TSA thing, double the entry thing.
It's not It's not the best way to grow an audience to pick a
[__] lane. That's obviously the best way to pick
the This isn't helping me. I lose subs over this. Every every
time Hutch, by the way, it's usually not me bringing up these
conflicts. Every time this It's usually like Hutch bringing in
lefties to talk to, which I'm fine with because I'm just going
to give my authentic take no matter what. And I'm just going
to tell how I see it. But it's not like I'm bringing in the lefties
to like poison everybody. It's just I'm reacting, having the
person you're doing that either. I think that people think that
people like you a piece. Like before everything happened, you
were like what? You were buddy of the year, right? >> No,
I I didn't you would be in content, right? Like you were you
were great. Like every pisto
>> Pisco just take care of just scratch Destiny's back
and then we'll scratch yours Pisco. Hey Pisco this is this is
the classic
Trump move right here. We're you want this to go good or bad
for you? Cuz I'm you. Do you want it to go good or bad?
Which which way do you want it to go? >> Let him piss like
changed. So have I changed? I haven't changed. I haven't changed.
I You think I changed? What have I changed on? Honestly, I I
don't know much that you have changed on to be honest. However,
this community switched and obviously Destiny's personal feelings.
I'm not going to speak for them because I don't know them. But
what I think is that you whether and I might be wrong. >> You
don't know them. Do you really not know them or are you just
are you just
your feelings are Destiny's feelings. You have Destiny's feelings
imprinted on you. You don't have your own brain waves. Your your
brain waves have been rewritten with Destiny's brain waves. >> In
this judgment or in my in my thought here, you might be trying
extra hard to get out of his shadow. And not I'm not trying to
say this insulting way or let me explain this. Not honest to
god I'm not trying like you don't want to be pisco the guy who
used to be on destiny stream and not hide the lawsuit because
you want to be around that makes sense right >> I'm not
embarrassed by my past I'm not embarrassed like destiny and I
lie more on politics and of course it made sense that for us
to like to be collaborating I had there's a reason why I came
to you to to set this [__] up I'm not embarrassed
by because what I thought I was doing was um helping the country
helping you know promote liberal values and uh instead of what
I think is more cringe kind of deadender socialism on some channels
and so I don't I'm not like embarrassed by by that [__]
like that's not the case right I'm not trying to the same embarrass
[laughter] Embarrass had nothing to do with it. It was more like
nobody wants to any any guy in his own career doesn't want to
be tied to somebody else who was who he was with in the beginning
>> flaws and all. I mean, you know, yeah, I I think it's
kind of like silly, especially because I don't go out of my way
to critique Destiny or go attack him. It's the opposite. I realize
that, right? It's the opposite. I don't think you do. It's literally
the opposite. So, I I get seen clips where it's like he's ascribing
that I'm doing this for money. Oh, peace knows what he's doing
here. It's not going to really like the reason doing that cuz
like
it's the most malicious obsessive
I might say ascribing of malice to me. I'm not going out of my
way to go disagree with him and go get under his that couldn't
be farther from the truth. >> Listen listen he's probably
really all stressed out. Listen how I can't imagine what I would
be going through what I would be thinking of other people if
I was in the middle of a crazy ass lawsuit if I have I'm not
saying you did this. I'm not saying you did this, but if I had
lost all of my
This is so embarrassing.
Oh, this needs to be documented. Make sure you archive this stream.
This needs to be documented. This is the weirdest, grossest I've
ever seen. He's just in here.
Can't you just think about the real victim here? Destiny so upset
about this. He's doxing people. That makes him the real victim.
my friends or people that I thought were my friends and no one
wanted to talk to me and everybody at the very beginning they
thought I was like
they automatically assumed the >> oh this guy's so lucky
this guy is so lucky that Pisco has taken a principled stance
against commenting oh yeah since the very beginning wait what
changed from the allegations at the very beginning what what's
changed at all
nothing literally the only thing we know is that he's admitted
to doing the exact thing he was accused of doing from the >> party
the other party and they thought I was this this monster. Like
I would be angry and suspicious and and attacking. >> I
would have a short >> I would be I would be I'd be lashing
out at everybody and I might perceive like certain actions in
a certain way whether that be right or wrong. And I feel like
you have to understand that as well. No, like that's at least
that's >> I'm not going out of my way to antagonize him
or DGG. I'm not doing that. I'm not going through my community
and banning DGers. There was a guy there's a there's a member
of our community. Um although keep in mind that DG has a special
rule in my community. No one else gets this except for Ethan
Klein. No Destiny related drama on the Discord. Already a special
protection. I'm sure there's no rule like that for Pisco in any
Discord or community or whatever. Already special protection
for them. But even putting that aside, there was um a value I'm
not even going to out right now, but a valid member of the community
who appeared on Destiny and was doing something really great
and we were all super encouraging and like proud of this person.
And it's not like I'm going out of my way to be like, "Oh, you
shouldn't interact." Like that's never you know I know that Hutch
and um
Soy Pill and I desa have they have I said don't interact with
Destiny don't no instead what has actually happened is a complete
mischaracterization which I can only take as bad faith for many
different reasons >> double my intention that my intention
is either money to ingratiate myself with people various different
people to oh he's touch my co-host
>> by the Hey, the reason Destiny continues to go after
Pisco is because Pisco is a better option to be like a liberal
influencer online. He's better at debating. He's better at researching.
He's more focused. He's not got the baggage. And if Pisco rises,
Destiny diminishes. There's nothing that you would want in Destiny
stream that you couldn't get from a Pisco stream if your goal
is politics. Pisco will take every serious political person from
Destiny. Destiny boot will be left with just being Ethan Ralph.
That's the only thing he'll have left. Every serious principled
interested like like advocate that exists will go to Pisco over
Destiny. And that is why Destiny has to attack him repeatedly
and try to denigrate his reputation. Try to denigrate him and
his reputation because Pisco is just better in every way for
serious politics. I by the way I would think, you know, in terms
of being funny, if you look at Desi from like 2021, Desi is way
funnier than Pisco is now. But in terms of actual serious political
drive debating polit political subjects it's not close. Pisco
is >> And did Hush say he felt my >> Yeah, a little
bit. But no, but but that were my intent. [laughter] I'm sorry.
>> No, but as though that were my intent, which of course
it's not. Why would I want to do that? >> I don't know.
Why does he feel that >> suck up to socialists? >> Why
there's a reason Hutch feels that way, dog? >> Yeah. Well,
I think that possible that he he thinks that I'm just trying
to [__] with him at some elements. I think that he
was I pressed him on the answer to that. The actual answer here
that Pisco doesn't want to say is no. I see who's in Hutch's
chat, too. I see who's in Hutch's chat. You think we couldn't
do this, by the way? Go find all of the people who are like trying
to get Hutch to go after Pisco and tie them all back. I could,
if I had the time, I could easily do this. Okay, I could very
easily do this. I don't have the time like some other people,
right? And so, you know, perhaps, but I don't think Hutch thinks
that I'm sweeping for tankies just to do it. What would explain
my behavior with ogre? You know, you don't get friends for being
perceived as defense. >> Easy target dog. >> No,
dude. Well, but the thing is I don't withhold criticism. >> Over
half [__] bro. Like, you think I hold criticism of
Assan? >> It's like punching a fat. What? >> You
think I hold criticism of Assan or any other lefty? >> No,
[laughter] I just don't understand it. Like, it really is to
me. >> Listen, I think there's it's it's >> You don't
think that I'm doing this because you said I'm a base lib. You
said I'm you know, it's sad because I'm like I don't know a lib
podcast even though that's not my goal. And usually when we're
fighting, it's about the best way to implement liberal strategy,
right? It's like and most of the time I just want to let you
know the majority of the panel agrees with me. You understand
that like in all these discussions on the shutdown on the nature
of Chuck Schumer stepping down on what we just said about the
hypotheticals with Assan versus other >> politicians in
a hypothetical matchup I'm in the majority of the panel whether
that was a econom boy or whether now it's in the majority and
so the special that's another way that you know it's bad faith
like has the same opinion I do >> of Assan [__]
the exact same and no one says well he's covering up for tankies
when he expresses that opinion no one we had a discussion with
Hutch and Jaziah where we were just saying the same thing all
of the entity is towards It doesn't make sense because it's not
premised on these issues. These are these are just pretexts.
>> But if so many people have this feeling and and so many
people that you consider your friends have this feeling, do you
think there's no like mass psychosis? >> Like do you think
that's just it's only mass psychosis >> and lies?
I mean take the issue just of global entry, right? Global entry
or something that is a liberal issue, right? About
somebody signed up for YouTube with the name Pisco's girlfriend
was 17.
>> viewpoint discrimination. And >> by the way, that's
that's even that's worse. That's an outright lie, right? That's
just an outright lie. So that would be open to I I assume being
>> No, no, no, no, no. I I believe he lied too about some
aspects of it. But Dustin and I agree. I have a clip of him saying
that he was likely because of uh things he said about Rick Scott
and other things, but at least on those based facts, there's
an agreement. Now, there's an interpretive question about well,
if it were based on these statements or the Houthi interview
or anything like that, if it were based on that, would that be
problematic? But that's not a factual dispute. That's like a
a legal interpretive dispute. But that issue was used where I'm
basically saying, "Yeah, the administration which before has
discriminated in the first term on global entry and which has
discriminated in this term on global entry for other people too
as well as every other aspect of immigration. They're checking
social media accounts in the same month in which this the Hassan
um deauthorization for global entry came down all this stuff
at the same time that in that context if I take a position this
is bad. I actually think it's you know they was put in discrimination.
What what [laughter] the how is that communist sweeping?" That's
not me saying anything like that.
you know, the settler baby conversation would taken so out of
context calling Hassan deplorable for not condemning his friends.
And I'm just saying he's not literally advocating for baby here.
He's saying it's would be legally permissible. He's wrong about
and that's wrong for its own sake. But it's it's it's no because
he doesn't tell a lie. The lie would be that he's advocating
for babies to be killed. >> That therefore I'm s for tanks
and I'm only watching that video because it was
>> right? Right. So the fact that I'm engaging with you
right now, you know, the fact that I bother to do like the probably
ignore all this like the easy thing for me to do would just be
banan references to Destiny, ban references to Hassan from my
chat and focus on law and focus on live stuff. Do you Zia does
that would be the easy way out?
>> I mean, would you be willing to speak with him? I >> I've
already spoke with him two times. Of course I would be. >> All right.
Would you be like let's uh let's bring him in. I think I saw
him in a way earlier. >> Yeah, but like is do you think
>> but you've been asking a lot of like I'm speaking as
like an outside >> I Pisco needs to just say here. Okay.
Yeah. Oh, we got to get Desie in here. Pisco needs to say, I
talked to Destie about this. He had no recommendations. He's
just going to come in here and virtue signal. He's going to try
to make me look bad. It is not a good faith conversation. It
is not a good faith conversation at all. He should not talk to
the person. >> And and he like you were asking me why do
you think he was saying calling you um or saying
at least I'm I'm happy. I'm afraid of no man. >> Are you
willing to cringe that I'm not doing this because of communism
or because I'm shooting for tankies or because I want to hurt
huts or because I want to make money. >> I do not I don't
think I'll let you know. If I wanted to make money and maximize
making money, I wouldn't do this. I left the job where I was
making a lot of money. No, don't ask me. I have seen you're doing
it because of money. >> I told I told everybody this like
the idea that Pisco is doing this for money in like the short
term. The only way Pisco is doing this for money is by building
something like out of concrete, right? He is making like the
parthonon. That's the only way he is making money here. He was
like in
he's hit a
he's making a lot of money. Okay. He was making a lot of lot
of >> I don't think you're doing it just because of the
money. But Ubie has >> he's just building something slowly
over time. He is not going to cash in his stream or his reputation
for anything
>> like $1,000 or maybe maybe at this point overall like
$900. He's given more to Connor. You understand that?
>> Is banned from my Discord. Maybe is banned from my Discord.
If I wanted to make money, I wouldn't do this.
Like I said, I don't think
it might just be >> Destiny is seething in his chat right
now about not being able to get you might have complete perfect
contentions, but other people just think differently. It could
just go all the way down to that. People have a different view
of what's better or what the better action would be. But >> like
the money thing just makes no sense. Like >> and I think
that's a small part of it. But like honestly like I never said
it was about money. That's what Destiny said. So I would bring
him up and talk with him about that. >> I might just do
that. But um I think we're cool, right? I mean do you have any
problem with me? >> No, I don't have any problem with you.
You were the one like, "Hey man, when I first came in I was like,
"Hey man, why are you so hot?"
>> I was doing a bit. I was doing a bit. >> I know.
But you say you weren't doing a >> That's part of the bit.
>> It's bits on bits on bit. No, of course I like I want
I want you to be a huge streamer one day, bro. Like you're entertaining,
you're smart, you're funny. Like, but like I also think that
when people maybe criticize you, >> it's it's coming from
a place like it might be a little spicy. It's emotional. I think
it's emotional. >> It's emotional because they like you.
>> Well, I don't know. I mean, you guys were friends for
a while. So, unless all that was fake, let's all that was a bit
>> No, I mean the sad part is, right, like here's here's
a little secret, right? way to totally make me pick the DG to
make me like angry is to like lie on me. That's like a very very
easy way to get me to be like that. People lie on me. >> That
is like probably not a good strategic move to like I'll tell
you who hasn't done that. The lefties.
Now, because I'm principled, I'm not going to like become a lefty
because they're nice to me. But the people who have lied to me
aren't lefties. Not me. >> Cuz they're trying to get in.
They're >> Well, and just in terms of stratas they're in.
>> But that is that's what I got to say. >> [__]
their slum. Oh god, I hate this mother. Um, >> yeah, but
like don't you want to convince them, bro? Like, don't you want
>> those guys? They're lost. They're lost. They're lost.
They're gone. It's like trying to convince MAGA. They're gone.
They're gone.
Adam doing? Then what's Adam doing? >> Adam who?
>> Oh, he's trying to get some of their audience. I guess
he's not going to convince Hassan. And it's good exposure for
him. It's a [__] market [clears throat] move, bro.
>> he's Griffin.
>> No, that's not one and the same. He wasn't pretending
to be anybody else than what he wasn't. >> Well, he's being
nice through and >> If I did that, you know that. >> It
seems. I don't really I don't think I've again, I don't think
I've ever seen Mockler go in super hard.
He's just a kid. >> You never seen him going hard. Are
you
>> Well, you know what I mean, Dan. This is when I think
you're being obtuse.
>> You know exactly what I mean. >> You're intentionally
obtuse.
>> The [__] >> Honestly, I think a lot
more would get done if if if
I did maybe I'll even host a couple's counseling. I could be
the
>> Because sometimes you need you need >> This is
so insanely parasocial. This is like the most parasocial calling
I've seen in my entire life.
>> It's actually crazy.
I'm
in no mood to
entertain
like overtures of reconciliation of any kind. Do you understand?
>> I'm not saying reconciliation, but you were the reason
I asked it originally was because you had said >> you were
asking me all these qu like about what Destiny thinks. I'm like,
I don't know what the [__] Destiny thinks. I'm at
Destiny.
>> That's why I said, hey, why like if you have all these
questions like you should just bring him in. I don't know. I
don't have all these questions. Like I I know what's going on.
It's it's it's anger uh emotion. It doesn't have anything to
do with like >> you can ask him instead of just assuming
>> he he's not going to cop to that
>> Well, let's just see >> who's waiting to join
up on Pisc.
>> Hey, how you doing? >> Whoa, that was loud. >> What's
going on, man? >> Not much. >> So,
I've been listening to uh to a bunch of this. I just have a few
questions just to clarify some things cuz I I don't fully know
what's going on. So during that debate I did see the clip Destiny
said that Aaron was a Marxist Linist, right?
>> Okay. And you said that you said that she wasn't and
you called that a Destiny
>> Okay. What What is Aaron then? >> Aaron is a communist.
>> Okay. I mean earlier in this uh in the stream you said
she was a liberal. Did you just misspeak?
>> No, I think that she believes in freedoms. Um, I understand
liberalism to entail protections of liberties.
Um, I guess usually it implies
>> protections from the state >> and communism kind
of entails a stateless society, but I think that she would round
out some theory of of rights and freedoms that would be enforced.
>> Is this about Aaron? >> Wait, did they make this
about Aaron? >> Absence of a state. Something like that.
But she does believe in freedoms like I'm looking at other stuff.
I just don't know that she believes in the state but the liberties
part of liberalism she
>> I mean she has private property though
>> um like I'm not a liberal >> okay then I will
grant that if she takes liberalism to be a commitment to you
know some sort of statebacked system of freedoms and rights
um then I'm assuming that's what she's talking about when I use
the term liberal as described to her what I'm suggesting is that
she's dedicated to democratic processes which she still believes
in and advocates for and for freedoms. That's all I mean.
>> Right. So would you be like like an anarco communist
then? Like what what flavor of communist we talking about >> I
think a flavor of communism which
um sees as its aspiration
>> the abolishment of the state >> abolishment of
private property. >> Oh man. >> And the protection
of
civil liberties communally. That's how I understand it. >> Man,
that sounds like a bad idea.
Well, whether it's a good or a bad idea doesn't really relate
to whether she's Marxist London or disagreed.
>> Yeah, it's true. I mean, there's there's there's the
larger conversation of all >> sharp talk is going to get
totally rolled here. I don't know why he did this.
So, I just Yeah. So, you were just saying something totally is
the coralary of that. Yeah. Yeah, that's true. >> Anarchism
ends up turning into some flavor of authoritarianism as soon
as you realize. >> You would agree that she's not a Marcist
>> So, like >> you would agree she's not a Marshallist?
>> I don't think she'd want to be. I think I think if you
gave her like >> Is she or is she not? Yes, sir. Is is
Is she a Marxist Lenist? >> I don't think I don't think
she'd want to be. She's sort of like a consequentially she becomes
a Marxist Leninist because her ideas lead to Marxist Leninist
winning. >> I'll tell you. I'll tell you. I think I think
if you gave her political power, she would have to be bounc
or is she not as it is now?
>> As it is right now. No. >> Okay. I was correct.
So, so just be clear. I was correct when I said she wasn't Marcus
on this. Sure.
Yeah. No, I >> Okay. And it was wrong it was wrong for
usurp it was wrong for us to suggest that all communists are
Marxist.
>> Oh yeah, that's obviously true. Yes. All communist Marxist.
>> And as though I didn't know wasn't that she was a communist.
>> So I think it was wrong to say like oh she's an ML.
I think that's that just wasn't what was in the clip. I still
think what she is is bad but not an ML. >> Okay. So when
you take a clip that doesn't show Marxist and says she's a communist
and pretend as though I've been sort of rebutted, that's a lie,
isn't it?
>> Virtually was lying there. I think he was ignorant for
a second. He's normal now. He just misspoke. Yeah. Yeah. I think
so. >> That's why I personally believe >> I I don't
because if he misspoke, he should own up to that, right? Say
I'm Wouldn't that be the correct thing to
>> Sure. I mean maybe maybe is listening here. I don't
know. But uh if he is I would say you know communism and Marxist
Linism are not the same thing. It's very obvious that straight
A's a communist. It's very obvious her ideas are bad. We don't
even call them evil. But Marxist Linist I don't think that she
is. No.
>> Any other questions for me? >> Yes. Actually um
I I do want a little bit of clarification on the whole um Rose
was 17 debacle because you said something along [laughter] the
lines of >> dude I just I really just think you should
be nicer to Destiny. I think maybe could you just like Destiny
again? I just wish you'd come in and it's just cringe that you
don't like Destiny. By the way, Pisco treats these people so
special. Okay, if I was doing the kind of brigading, if anyone
was doing the kind of brigading they do on his channel, he'd
ban them all from his community. I I feel like I can almost guarantee
that.
It's there's just no way anyone else would be allowed to. >> You
don't want to venture into the topic. If you ban this person,
it would be taking a stand on this this story. You don't want
to take a stand on No, I understand. Um, just hypothetically,
like if Destiny had a chatter that was named, I don't know, peace
go straighter, would you expect him to ban that person? >> Um,
I wouldn't expect him to ban that person currently. >> Well,
why? What? I mean, I think it's reasonable to expect him to ban
that person. That's that's a crazy name. >> Well, then
the name itself might violate
>> I'm not sure. [laughter]
>> Put aside to I mean moral issues. I mean morally. I
mean morally. >> Right. right now. You think that he would
ban that person?
>> I would hope so. If it were my >> it would just
be your payment. >> I would ban someone like I I've had
>> $3 trying to classify an underage person. BTW I label
minor is an anagram of omniliberal.
>> Hey, thank you very much Ruben Rubin for reminding us.
I would just say does Destiny currently ban people who dox people
in Australia >> really really bad disputes with other creators
um in the past and I' I'd definitely ban them if it were if it
were me. >> Okay. So you think that I should ban people
who make allegations or whose names are
>> I mean if if they're allegations. Yeah. Especially if
they're if they're not founded. Yeah. >> Okay. So on that
view
should I ban Destiny for making a allegation as to Ethan Klein?
>> Maybe you should. I don't know to be honest. I'm asking
if it were the case. No. So, it's a conditional. If it were the
made a baseless accusation,
>> then yes, you should.
>> I um I think >> that's how I view it. >> As
I sit back and think, I think that um
there are probably some bullets that I'd bite in terms of
moderation of certain names in my community.
But I think that this particular name is asking me to venture
into an issue which is like squarely in the heart of things which
I think I have a commitment not to venture into.
You think it's unprincipled for me to take the stand. Do you
think I should ban this person? Is it their name? >> Yes.
Yes, you should. And in fact, the fact their name keeps appearing
on your stream on a topic that you you've said yourself you don't
want to talk about. I mean, they're still appearing there on
your stream. They're in your VOD. They're in your videos. So
that's a good point. That is in in a way appearing there. Are
they Wait, wait, wait. But are they commenting on it or is it
like a name that's a reference that you'd have to know the reference
and explain why they're getting banned? >> I said I won't
talk about it. You think I should ban all mentions of it in my
>> Maybe. Yeah. If you're going to take that kind of principal
sentence, then maybe that's the right thing to do. >> Anything
I don't talk about, my community shouldn't mention.
>> Um, if it's going to be that inflammatory, I think so.
That's pretty
>> I'm just wondering if I would apply this to other people.
That's a point that I hadn't considered before which is if I'm
unwilling to discuss something doesn't make sense to allow other
people discuss in the app but it's there's a range of issues
which I probably like I probably would be unwilling to discuss
certain allegations
like Hassan etc.
I'm not sure I'll think about it because I haven't I haven't
thought about that
yeah sure um any yeah I just these are just things that I um
I didn't quite know what was going on here so I just wanted some
clarifications on the uh on the books. Thanks for having me on.
>> No that's good. Hey, thank you so much. And were you
on the debate with Wick as well with usurp?
>> Uh, I don't know who usurp is. I was on last night,
>> but it was um it was me, Destiny, and then two right-wingers
debating is Trump a threat to to free speech. And it was two
like no name guys. No offense to them. Uh because we couldn't
get any right-wingers to actually pick up the other side. None
of them wanted to debate it. I even I called in all the old right-wingers
who have hated me now for years because I apparently backstabbed
them. None of them show up to the debate. >> Even though
they had to have a big beef with me, they wouldn't show up. Oh,
>> Well, um I've had some trouble in similar circumstances.
We had one um about the Comey indictments and they really scraping
the bottom of the
>> I think I was on that panel with you >> Oh, yeah.
Yeah. >> But anyway, thank you so much for Yeah.
>> No, it was it was that one redheaded guy who was like
kind of sick halfway through it and he like apologized for how
bad he was and it's like, "Listen, man. You shouldn't have done
this
>> It was uh it was a tough moment for them, but appreciate
>> like Pisco's reaction to the previous drama, by the
way, where Destiny wouldn't make a recommendation. Pisco's reaction
to that was, "You don't get to discuss it in my Discord anymore."
Now, they're all back with the exact same accusations after Pisco
shut it down in his Discord. They're all back with the exact
same accusations for him. He took a special action in their favor
trying to prevent this kind of drama and they're back doing the
same kind of lying about him a few months later.
What does that tell us? I feel like it's obviously pushing us
in the direction of well these people are just anybody who doesn't
like Destiny they're they're going to keep blowing up about they're
going to keep getting mad about. Doesn't matter if the things
those people say are true doesn't none of it matters right they're
going to keep just going after Pisco for it. They're going to
keep trying to pressure Pisco. >> Hit you and um
>> goal, especially in the interim, especially in the short
term, is the defeat of fascism. I believe that the Republican
party >> No, you don't. No, you don't actually believe
this because you just want another form of fascism. It's called
Stalinism. It's called now. That's why you're a cryptofascist.
You're the same exact thing as MAGA. You brought forth MAGA and
so you're exactly the same. You don't have the same goal. And
these people shouldn't be treated like they have the same goal.
I don't know why Adam isn't like speaking up right now. if he
maybe Assan has some like dirt on him or something or maybe he's
got like weird sit I don't even know an illiberal party a post-lberal
party whatever you want to call it and I think unlike
uh the uh historic inception of fascism as a revolutionary movement
at a time when liberalism was failing only a hundred years ago
this time we have two liberal parties in America like as as a
political theory we have two liberal parties right like we say
conservative whatever but like technic >> no it's better
now. It was not good at the start and people weren't giving me
the actual time stamp. Now it's getting >> Republicans
are also a liberal uh party.
>> and am I laring right now? Wait, are you serious? Wait,
wait, Kinda, just to be clear, Kinda,
you think that you agree with Adam that we're all united in one
goal, that he's not here to shame anybody for voting one way
or voting another, that it's ridiculous to get commitments from
Newsome if he's the nominee, that we're going to agree a lot
on terms of criticism of the Democratic party and where the party
needs to go. Am I laring right now? Wait, are you serious? Wait,
wait, Kinda, just to be clear, Kinda,
you think that you agree with Adam that we're all united in one
goal, that he's not here to shame anybody for voting one way
or voting another, that it's ridiculous to get commitments from
Newsome if he's the nominee, that we're going to agree a lot
on terms of criticism of the Democratic party and where the party
needs to go, and that he should be conceding that he's disillusioned
with the Democratic party.
I'm going to say Pisco's too to know that Kinda is disabled.
Okay? He's too realize that he doesn't know.
That's not his fault >> in front of us. I just want to
make sure. Kinda, do you agree with all of what Adam said there,
Kinda? >> This is just for Kinda. Those are all things
that Adam said and you're gonna pretend that you're okay with
that. >> Not cool, man. Not cool. Not cool. Very not cool.
>> Cuz we'll have Kinda on right now just to discuss those
points. It's been a minute in this discussion and we've already
had five concessions.
>> Okay. I seen, by the way, I've seen like five DGers
and zero people. I Oh, no. Sugar is someone I recognize. Although
I don't think they're super political,
but I've seen like five DJers and no none of these like crazy
leftists yet. We'll see. I'm sure they'll show up. Oh, hold on.
There's there's one. [laughter]
>> Not entirely, but I wouldn't go as hard as you are.
[laughter]
>> NO, PISCO. NO, SHE'S she's totally taking it seriously.
Oh, no. Oh, no. >> What the Oh, dude. Why would you ever
as a liberal streamer go in front of a tanky anti-semite like
Hassan [__] want a a productive conversation as though
it's possible with a bad faith hack? Quote, "We're all united
in one goal." You need to understand that he's a tanky. He's
anti-liberal. They use liberal as a slur.
Then Adam says he's not here to shame anyone for voting one way
or not voting the other. And you're like, "Uh, it's not that
bad. It's not that bad."
Dude, [sighs and gasps]
>> you have no response, right?
Clinda, you have no response.
You think that that's okay. That before any debate, you
>> She She's starting to get it and she has to say this
is great. I don't I don't believe she'll believe it's great,
but >> We should have a productive conversation with a
bad faith hack, >> that we're all united in one goal. Here,
I'm quoting. I'm quoting, right? This is in fact, we can go right
back to the >> We haven't even started a discussion. And
he's already conceded. You guys, I know you want me to pull up
DGG logs. I can pull up screenshots of specific logs sometimes,
but you have to understand I'll never be able to just pull up
DGG wholesale because it's the same as pulling up a bad empanada
video without looking up looking up anything in it, right? Or
or watching it. Like you cannot you cannot platform like do like
places you know docs are or where they're at a high risk of platforming
somebody's docs. You can't search through those without knowing
what's there.
Like you you can't do that. Unironically, I'm saying this totally
seriously. You cannot do that. Marma, dude, thank you very much
for the 500. >> Pisco needs to fully take the gloves off.
Stop placating Destiny, who's now doing the same creulying he
accused others of. >> Yeah, I think Pisco is doing that.
I don't have to do anything. I'm just I'm
uh how do I put it?
Oh, also
yes, I think he's doing that already. I'm just uh I Nothing.
There's nothing. I just think he's doing it already. There's
actually nothing else to add. So, thank you very much for the
500 kicks. Marma dude, I also forgot to thank Trucker Nate earlier
for the 500 kicks. Thank you so much, Trucker Nate. I really
appreciate it. >> He wants to have a productive conversation.
We're all united in one goal. He's not here to shame anybody
for voting one way or not voting another one way, for voting
one way or not voting one way. He thinks it's ridiculous to get
commitments to vote for Newsome. And we're going to agree a lot
in terms of criticism of the Democratic party and where the party
needs to go. Oh,
wait. No. I'm just asking you specifically. Isn't that up that
he would do this, Kinda? that he would concede at the start like
this. >> Oh no, Kinda is definitely going to be on. Isn't
there some talking point about how Adam was being consiliatory
to get Hassan to say like really really incorrect or incoherent
things and that by Adam was playing like 40 chess and was finding
a way to make Hassan say like totally inconsistent things, but
like that's why he let Hassan talk the whole time. I think there's
some talking points like that out there that there's some [__]
going on. >> What? This isn't debate mode. What are you
talking about? Wait. User, can you uh I just want you to join.
You can call me, right? Can you
you want to call right now?
I just want to get uh
>> debate mode. Oh, did this surf guy? >> We We might
have to watch Dude, do we just do me? Am I going to have to start
with the other might have to start with that other content tomorrow
or something? God damn it.
>> this is my first time watching. >> This is rough,
man. This is rough. Do you think Destiny Hutch's gaslighting
worked on Pisco? I don't think Hutch was gaslighting. I think
he genuinely I I said like I do think Hutch is probably somewhat
like annoyed. You read mean comments about yourself, you're always
annoyed. Even if you've done something to like bring those mean
comments on, even if they're like accurate but mean comments.
You're always annoyed with somebody who like would allow that
to happen. It's about whether or not it's fair to expect them
to do something. I always knew Hutch was annoyed. I said as much
when we when he first came in. I just thought, "Oh, well, he's
not going to let his friend get over. he's not going to work
with like this um like I thought he basically the way I saw it
was he's capable of seeing like a bigger picture and that he's
not going to sue Pisco right now cuz Pisco could you know Hutch
could have done a lot of damage to Pisco I don't think he did
as with what he said but I do think I do think Pisco was like
totally crushing Destiny until Hutch came in and was like no
I've actually mentioned your chat to you a
um unlucky because you get you just get to paint Pisco as like
totally um as like lying. They'll just say Pisco is lying about
not knowing that Hutch wanted some moderation or something, right?
That's where it'll go. So, it's too bad cuz Pisco totally dominated
the conversation, but it won't matter now. Unlucky, man. Unlucky.
Not that like I guess I should be realistic. It would never have
mattered to those people ever in the first place,
right? It would never have mattered to those people
like like they already hate Pisco.
So it it just actually the the concrete reality is this doesn't
matter, man.
But it would have looked good for, you know, hypothetically like
three people.
Ban all tankies from this chat right now. I would have no viewers
if we banned all the tankies. Oh, no. >> I'm quoting. Okay.
Well, all right. We'll go right back to the start and we'll see
if I misrepresented anything of what I just said. that Kinda
and usurper are now sweeping for Adam who's sweeping for Hassan.
Just keep that in
>> Let me fix that. >> Yeah. And I'll also up your
volume as
>> It's getting funnier. It's getting >> Yes. A few
things. [snorts] Um let me make sure you can hear me correctly.
>> Yeah, I can hear you. I crank. >> I want this
to be a productive
>> That was the first thing I said. He wants it to be a
productive conversation. That was accurate.
But Hassan is a bad faith piece of he is incapable of having
productive
>> He's like a Marxist Leninist who yeah he lies about
everything except when he like says something bad. If he says
the word re-education then he's like then he's like mask off.
Okay. But when he says things like I I like democracy. I want
to I want to achieve like some socialist goals through democracy.
That's mask on. He's just hiding. He's lying. Okay. He only wants
to embed himself within the Democratic party when he had the
conversation with Oh, what are these stinky [__]
cult >> the D program? Oh no, now I'm now I'm actually
starting my ears are actually burning. Maybe Pisco.
Maybe he actually is watching a little bit. >> It's called
the D something. Ooh, the D something. What is it called? >> Oh
no, >> the distributor. >> I didn't mean to do this.
I'm sorry. I'm >> Drogram. The drogram podcast.
Do you see? Did you see the aerodyite debate? Yeah. I find me
clips. I will never ever watch whatever ever again. If whatever
starts bounding in the thing to like 2 hours or something, maybe
8 8 hour 47 minutes off. What trash content. He said he was going
to embed himself by hiding his views.
And Adam wants to have a productive conversation with you. You
need to know you're not going to have productive conversation
with someone whose only job is to defeat the Democratic party.
So that's number one. I wasn't wrong about that. He did say he
wanted a productive conversation. That shows he's naive. >> I
want to make sure we can make >> Yeah, just call me on
VC
and I'll call
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. >> Am I good to call conversation
and acknowledging and conceding that we're all we quotes and
representations are >> Also, I have to get like water and
a pop and I'm going to grab some of that food. I got sushi like
rolls as well. So, I'm gonna hope those are like defrosted.
I sat outside for a while, but hopefully I'm actually going to
try to eat something because I've not eaten anything yet. I'll
be right back. >> For anyone who doesn't know, that's my
I froze my sushi order when I first started the stream. It's
[__] up. >> So, one productive >> sitting
on my >> I left it sitting on my doorstep for like two
hours at the start of my stream. It was messed up. Okay, >> I
think we're all united in one goal of >> He says we're
all united, including Hassan. we we are all united in one
His first statements are saying he wants to have a productive
conversation and acknowledging and conceding that we're all on
the same page. That is Adam sanewashing Hassan. Do you understand
how that's saneashing Hassan? He's conceding that we all share
the same goal. I'm going to call you. Wait, this is actually
really harmful. I'm calling you a ser.
>> Wait, wait, wait. I was away. I was away. I was away.
What did Pisco just say? Did he just say what I think he just
said? There's no way. >> I'm going to call you. Wait. >> Did
I go far enough? >> This is actually really harmful. I'm
calling you, assur.
>> Oh, I didn't go back far enough. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. >> Did say he wanted a productive conversation.
Why he would start this >> Hold on. Hold on. Come on. Hold
on. >> Hang on. Just make sure my rest the rest of my quotes
and representations are accurate. So, one productive >> some
progress because I think we're all united in one goal of beating.
>> He says we're all united, including Hassan. We we're
all united in one goal. His first statements are saying he wants
to have a productive conversation and acknowledging and conceding
that we're all on the same page. That is Adam sanewashing Hassan.
Do you understand how that's saying washing Hassan?
what he's cons
what
what did he just did he just
why would he say that? Why would he say that? Why would he Why
would he say that? Why would he say those words? Why would he
say that? >> Seeding that we all share the same goal.
>> I didn't even grab my sushi. I just came back to do
that bit. One second. >> I'm going to call you. Wait. This
is actually really harmful. I'm calling you. Yo, what up? Wait,
can you hear me? Oh, one second. I can't hear you.
Can't hear you. One sec.
How about now? >> Uh, can you hear me? I can hear you loud
and clear. Can you hear me? >> Yeah. How you doing, bro?
>> I'm doing well, man. How you doing? Not so well, man.
My first time listening to this [__] >> Listen,
I don't I didn't I didn't come in saying that you made any misrepresentation.
Just seem they turned on the stream. You just seem hot. And >> yeah,
no, I I'm kind of hot because like >> he's like 10 or 20
seconds into this debate and he's said that he wants to have
a productive conversation with a bad face. He's a hack and that
we're all united in one goal. I think he's like conceding the
framing. He's conceding the framing that we're all on the same
team. We're part of the same coalition and he's sane Hassan.
Would you agree with that?
I mean, I guess so in the way if you just wanted to do that,
but can I give you a counter about
>> Yeah. Now I'm starting to see why um
now I'm seeing why Pisco had to die today. Why they had to go
and try to sue this guy again, right? Like literally the idea
the idea that you could have a productive conversation with leftists
right now. Um yeah, Pisco's got to go down today. I I see I see
I see what happened.
I see it. I see it. Wait, wait, wait. When you say in a way,
what do you mean in a way? >> Because I would only imagine
because you said it was the first 20 seconds and I can imagine
somebody coming in. I don't know if these guys have ever talked
before and I can just see you not wanting to come in swinging
fist right away. You might want to come in, you know, just being
cordial, being polite, trying to see maybe you can have a normal
conversation, but if I can understand if you don't like if you
think that he doesn't deserve any of that credit at all, then
I'm just I can see how you might think that. >> I think
you've he's already given up at the start because like we need
to excise these people from our coalition. Like Hassan is waiting
>> because I can This is what I was asking when I Well,
this is what I meant when you came in hot. You just It just seems
that I don't know the conversation you had with um with Hutch
the other day like it just you just seem different
>> I don't know how you mean in the conversation with Hutch,
I never made it like even close to the impression that I thought
Hassan's on the same team. I said he was mostly bad faith. I
said he was illiberal. And so I I would was very clear I was
very clear in our conversation was talking nice to him. I wasn't
saying you were like glazing him but you weren't like this. And
I think if you don't know what I mean when I do this and you're
just >> because I view Hutch as an ally part of the coalition
and I think he just has a wrong impression of me that I would
support someone like Assan. So that doesn't really get me animated
cuz I'm just trying to basically have good communication with
him. The reason I was hot is because Adam is literally saying
watching a tanky >> and and so like
I'm nice with Hutch because he's part of the coalition and I'm
trying to convince him that I am part of the coalition and I'm
more hot when I hear a liberal try to wash us on and conceal.
Okay, hold on. Pisco is really good at smiling during the bit.
Oh, no he's not. Sorry, not smiling. Not ever smiling during
the bit. He's not actually Pisco had to learn how to smile. Okay.
He's he's like he he didn't know how to smile growing up and
he's never been taught. Didn't have that emotion. Okay. He just
didn't that him feeling happy is not connected to him smiling.
So actually the thing you're perceiving is that the illusion
that he smiles a lot otherwise is just a learned behavior. Okay.
That's all it is. >> See that we're all going towards the
same goal when we're very clearly not. >> Can I >> He's
just he's actually just relaxing when he doesn't smile ever during
the
>> Can I ask if you if like you're are you changing your
method in which you're doing it now? Like are you saying that
now you're acting a little hotter? >> No, I've always been
hot against Hanky like Assant.
>> I've always said that they're not part of the team.
Yeah, I've always said >> Yeah, I think you always said
I think you've always said that they've like haven't necessarily
been part of the team. But I also think that like while you haven't
been like glazing them or supporting them or even agreeing with
a lot of their ideas, you've kind of given them a little bit
of a benefit of the doubt like is not even like in a bad way,
but you're a nicer guy when you have these conversations like
necessarily like when you go up against a person like Rob Nure.
Yeah. you're going to go at his throat because he's a mega- conservative
and they're disgusting creatures and they're so obviously not
on our side. But I think that you had almost a thought of, you
know what, these guys are might be farther left than us. They
might actually be communist and they might actually want some
crazy stuff, but you know what, the enemy of the enemy is my
friend and my real enemy over there, MAGA, is so bad that I'll
even attempt to be cordial with people on the left, further left
than me. And I think that's what you were doing before. So,
>> so you surf guy is suspicious but not sure. Well, you
missed the very embarrassing part of this debate a little earlier,
Semaphore, where this usurp guy was talking to Pisco and literally
was like begging to moderate a conversation between Pisco and
Destiny.
>> Okay. Very, very embarrassing. I guess >> even
if I were to concede that even if I were to concede that, >> which
I don't concede, even if I were, that's what Adam's doing here
in a much more sympathetic and sane washi way that I even could
be ever accused of. I would never do this concession that we're
all towards the same goal of Hassan
I didn't come, >> but I got criticized by people for how
I went. And so this is even worse even if you believe them than
that. And so I know this can't be >> again. I [clears throat]
think it's different when it's the first 20 seconds of the conversation,
especially if you don't know how the rest goes cuz maybe after
the 5minute mark, it's a blood bath. Not that you don't know
that yet. >> Well, I just want to know like if he were
ever to say something like I don't know um that he doesn't even
consider it
endorse Kamala, he doesn't hold it against him. If you were to
ever say something like that, I mean that would be saying >> No,
it wouldn't just be that. I mean, no, [laughter] this isn't this
isn't a real debate. You that they're not really having conversation
right now. >> I don't think Adam I don't even know if Adam
came in as a debate because even like he was calm the entire
time cuz I've watched I didn't watch all of it or like I was
just I was doing other stuff when I was listening to it. But
even like Hassan at one point um said like, "Hey, you like brought
up like, "Oh, you're bringing up like a debate bro strategy when
I think for the most time Adam was just trying to have a quiet."
Wait, since you got the Hassan line open, you got to get the
Pisco tiny combo reacted to on stream. Um,
no, I don't think so.
And one, I wouldn't abuse my connection my deep
my deep connection to Hassan. Okay, I wouldn't use it like that.
That would be weird. Okay.
But I don't think I don't think this is the kind of thing Hassan
would react to.
You'd have to get somebody on the page of understanding
that Destiny's trying to do some of the same things he did to
Hassan or anyone else who's broken out of his community. You'd
have to get him to understand that. I don't know if Hassan's
picking that up yet. We'll see. >> I conversation. I think
maybe his >> No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. You can't
have a quiet conversation with these people. You need to go in
there and make make them know that they're not welcome in our
coalition. this like it would be like trying to go into the MAGA
space and just glaze them and be like it's okay that you voted
for Trump. It's not okay. >> Well, it could you have a
conversation with somebody that you disagree with in a way that
you're acting calm and by and by you acting calm and just asking
kind of the same questions over and over again, it ends up making
the other person look bad anyway, even though you weren't confrontational
and hostile during [clears throat] the conversation. >> I'm
not so sure about that. I'm not so sure about that. >> Wait,
wait. >> I Yeah. No, I don't really think that that can
happen.
>> Explain that. Well, you remember I made this mistake
with the Vanguard, you know, a week or two ago where
>> I was nice or whatever and I just >> That can't
possibly be true or else you wouldn't have been able to accuse
Pisco of like sweeping for tankies obviously, >> Just kept
asking if they would support the Democratic party and I realized
that that was saying Washington some tanky who are the enemy.
All these people are the enemy and so I've been convinced by
people like um you know just like random people whoever that
that that's not good. So no just like random people. >> Yeah,
you weren't you weren't here for this earlier. Ethan Klein and
Totally Not Kosher Kathy. You you definitely you weren't here
earlier, but um I know that you get mad at me for defending Loader
Box all the time. And then they're like, "Oh, I think I think
JTO he uses Jtock talking points." It's like one
I've explicitly like pushed back on that idea multiple times,
including when Hassan said it. I said that's like, you know,
you're you know you're making that up, right?
And two, I called to sought out even when he tweeted something
that was hinting at that before.
Right.
And
three, I've talked to Loterbox in private about how I don't appreciate
that kind of convers that kind of talk. And he's like I I literally
have talked to Loterbox about this before, like specifically
the chatters. And I correct the Lonerbox's dad was a Garinite
every single time it's brought up. Like anytime I see that in
chat, I say that's insane. Don't don't say that. Obviously.
So, I don't know. It's like
there's just evidence like Loader Box has literally talked to
me about this stuff.
Well, he was a Marinite. Oh, whatever. That he was at Saburn
Chhatilla and killed a bunch of Palestinians. Whatever the I
don't know if he was flangist. Why did I say why did I say Marinite?
I meant fangist.
They say that his dad was a flangist at Saburn Chhatilla. I said
Maronite instead of fangis earlier tonight now and I look
sorry I don't if you don't like talked about this stuff very
often it goes out of your head. No it's not nitpicky they were
they were the philangists. That was the name of the militia.
It's not nitpicky. It's just true.
I feel for saying it like that earlier today.
Whatever you continue I'm almost done with this. >> Okay.
I mean listen I think I listen I think everybody knows you're
trolling and I understand why you're doing this. You're having
like an extreme reaction to the conversations that you've been
>> An extreme reaction. This is an it's an extreme reaction.
What is this? >> Extreme reaction compared to your normal
stream personality. Yeah. >> I don't know what you're talking
about.
>> Wait. Come on, dude. >> I legit know what you're
talking about. So, he's
How dare Pisco meme? How dare Pisco have fun? Are you having
fun on your stream? That's a bit of an extreme reaction, don't
you think? H like I know that the guy who I post clips for, the
guy who I'm most aligned with politically, the guy who I show
for all the time, I know he just called for you to get kicked
off of your own podcast,
but like don't you think you're having a bit of a an extreme
reaction to that? Don't you think this is like a bit extreme,
man? Don't you think you're like being a bit
>> He starts off the debate. This Sorry, it's not a real
debate. This is even a conver like go through this debate. >> Yeah,
sure. Let's do it. Yeah. Yeah. It's It's not a real conversation,
though. I just want you to know that. Can you admit it's not
a real
>> Well, you haven't watched it. How would you know? Well,
so far I can already tell this is not a real debate. This is
this is a debate. >> Oh, did somebody watch it? Someone
is a real debate. How will I do this? Can you share your screen
in
100%? Yeah, I can do that. All right. You >> I want this
to be a productive conversation. I want to make sure we can make
some progress because I think we're all united in one goal of
beating fascism at the end of the day. And I'm >> Can I
just Can I just agree that he should have said that at the start,
right? Yes or no? >> He shouldn't have said we're all in
it together to defeat fascism. >> Yeah, he shouldn't have
said that. Correct. Cuz it's wrong. It's it's a lie. So, he shouldn't
say You agree it's wrong, right? Because we're not we don't have
the same goal. So, it's untrue. Correct. Well, I guess is it
untrue? Yes or not right now? No. No. I'm asking if if the same
is true.
>> The statement is true. Wait, so Hassan and Hassan's
Hassan's end political goal wouldn't necessarily be fascism.
So yeah, right now their goal would be to unite to defeat fascism
in Hassan's ideal world after that fact. Then he would then defeat
the liberals to get communism and Mauism or Stalinism, whatever
you want, whatever of the month >> So you wouldn't have
a problem with me saying that Hassan and I share the same goal
of ending fascism. If I were to say that, you would have a problem
with
>> No, I guess it would. But I think the conversation goes
a little bit deeper than that. >> Well, I just mean that
statement in isolation. Correct. >> Yeah. Exact. Yeah.
In isolation. But you're but actions aren't in isolation. >> Yes.
Of course. I I totally agree. >> For voting one way or
not voting one >> Uh I don't like that concession either.
So he said he's not here to shame people for voting one way or
the other. Shouldn't he be shaming people? Why isn't that like
bad? >> I disagree with him on that one. Yeah. >> Okay.
So that that's horrible. >> I honestly don't even think
you guys all have to line up behind Gavin Newsome two years before
the [__] primary. >> That's up. He's saying
he's preending. >> 100% normal. Yeah. No, it's normal.
>> Wait, it's normal. >> No one was saying that.
Yeah. No one was saying that Hassan needed to get behind Gavin
Newsome now. that he was asked in a hypothetical election when
it was JD Vance and Gavin Newsome. >> Oh, you think this
comment is just for the primary? >> Wait, what? >> This
do you think the comment about we don't need to line up to support
Gavin Newsome? You think that he said that just with respect
to the primary, not the general? >> I think he said that
as in like, hey, we haven't gone through the primary process,
right, yet? So, we don't need everybody to get behind this one
>> Oo, that is ultra good faith. That is Do you understand
how this is? Cuz it's ultra good faith. You're trying to find
any way to even conceivably slightly
be good faith about how he's interpreted the state in the most
charitable most [__] charitable way possible. But
when you know other people say [__] yo calm down
calm down when this guy when why did he bring up this question?
Why did he make make that statement at him >> He's clearly
referencing. You got to be a [__] idiot. He's clearly
referencing the >> [__] whole controversy.
Obviously >> the Jennifer Welsh one. Yeah. What was the
question that Jennifer Welsh asked? >> Yeah. If they want
>> I'll be I'll be real.
I do think Pisco's been watching the stream. Okay. I think Pisco
is like my biggest fan. Pretty sure he's been watching the stream
a lot. Doing a lot of references, a lot of callbacks to the stream.
All right. I It's hard not to think so. Okay. >> On the
primary, obviously. Yeah. So, why would he say you don't have
to get behind him now? Yeah. Because he's trying to give him
cover. >> It's so up. Okay. It's so up that Pisco, Destiny,
and Hassan are all watching and they won't direct. Only Only
Destiny will direct people to my stream. Okay, sorry. I I didn't
want to I didn't give him props there. And I should give them
props. Okay, out of these three, they're all watching at the
same time. And Destiny's the only one who will direct people
to my stream.
It's so up, man.
It's so up.
God, it's so messed up, man. >> And sweep for his answer
there. >> You'd think I get a shout out. He might ask some
questions later on. He's already given away the store. thinks
that, hey, you're allowed to to um promote and support anybody
through the Democratic primary, >> right? But the context
say, but the context here is Hassan is already he's already said
that he won't after the general. And so by saying this, it makes
it appear to a neutral audience that he's okay with Hassan's
um broader outlook on Gavin Newsome and he's okay with all the
slander and that on a daily basis um Hassan [__]
will spread about Gavin Newsome. The framing so the framing no
no the framing is obviously here is sane washing overall outlook
on Gavin Newsome. By the way, if you're like a leftist tanky,
I don't have enough representation of those in my Discord. So,
discord.gg/jstlk,
hop in, okay? Only leftist tankies. We've got enough liberals.
We've got enough overt fascists. Way too many, in fact. But if
you're a leftist tanky, okay, we need you in the Discord. We
need participation from you guys in the Discord. Okay. So, discord.gg/jdk.
Hop in, please. Thank you.
>> Yeah. On this one, but >> wait, wait. So, so you
wouldn't have a problem with me like going and saying, you know,
I I don't I'm not asking you to sign up to support Gavin Newsome.
That's an okay thing to say.
>> So, so far >> support anybody. However, at the
end of the day, when it's on election day on November 4th, whatever
it is this year, you're goddamn right. If it is Gavin Newsome,
you stand behind him.
>> Okay. Well, hopefully he'll get that concession in this
video. >> Well, I mean, that's what he's probably going
to try to do. I hope because that was the big thing with the
Jennifer W. I would I would hope
I would hope he would ask the hypothetical again, right? If he
doesn't, that would be like Horrible.
>> I mean, he's what? You He's a kid.
>> Wait, are we doing this whole Michael? Michael Michael.
Uh, >> no. I'm just You're almost acting as a What? No.
Hold on. Piss off. >> He's a kid. >> Stop. Stop.
He's just a kid, man. You know what? But are you Are you seriously
trying to say that every conversation needs to be perfect?
>> Do you really think? Cuz I feel like
>> I want you to steal my I want you to try to steal my
position. Just steal my position. You really think I said that?
>> Yeah, I did. No, I'm not obviously saying that. I'm
obviously saying that the main as man that's why I said you're
being so hot. >> No, I'm not hot at all. I'm just I'm just
mad because he's trying to embed himself in the party and Adam
who's on mightest touch one of the biggest liberal streamers
is basically giving at least some optical cover for Hassan [__]
and approaching this in a friendly manner and in that sense at
least the framing you'd agree is sane Washington. The very fact
that he's here and it's >> hostile mean so far. >> We're
about 10 seconds in.
>> Okay,
I think that proves my point more than anything. But >> why?
Wait, why does that prove your point? Because you're because
you this is obviously all for show. Like we all know that this
isn't what you're actually upset about. You're upset about other
things and you're just kind of >> So So you think I shouldn't
be upset? Wait, I shouldn't be upset when like someone saying
watches a danky.
>> Well, no, you should be. But I also we also all realize
that it was conversations you've had earlier this week that are
leading you to act like this in the show.
>> Okay. No, no, no. Okay. Okay. Gay. This guy does this
guy is identifying that Pisco is doing a good or bad. It's not
right or wrong. Are you telling me that I shouldn't like update
how I approach these conversations in response to suggestions
about how light I'm going on
>> You could, but there's also something called like overcorrection.
>> You think I've overcorrected so far by calling out and
saying we have the same
>> Yeah, I would say right now you are overcorrecting.
Yeah.
The argument is this uh that Pisco like believes you should be
able to talk to lefties and this guy is going to always be upset
about Hassan and so Pisco is doing an overt like satire on people
who want you never to talk to lefties, right? And this guy's
upset that Pisco is making fun of lefties the whole time. Okay.
Also, I think this guy was was basically trying to say that Pisco's
chat is like a lefty chat that they're like insane and he was
on that whole thing. All right. And Adam right now is doing excellent,
right?
We've I've watched like 15 seconds, dude. How the hell am I going
to judge his performance primary? We have an exciting ideological
battle coming up. So, I'm not asking you to like jump up and
down for Gavin Newsome. However, I do want to talk about your
response to Jennifer Welch on that podcast. >> I know I
I don't think I don't think this guy is biting down on this.
I think he can understand that Pisco is doing the opposite of
his opinion right now. >> I think we this is good. [clears throat]
He's like he's >> have some thoughts and I think
version of what a lot of people on Twitter are trying to say
but kind of getting muddled in. But, um yeah, we're going to
agree on a lot regarding criticism. >> No, it's not getting
muddled. Like, I hate this. He's already pre-apologizing for
liberal commentators who are in Assange's replies. >> I
think it is getting muddled a little bit like I for I can just
think of one muddle from this conversation which was the hey
would you um would you support him in the or would you support
Gavin Newsome against JD Vance in the election and he said no
and now other people defending Hassan are saying hey everyone
wants us to line up behind Gavin Newsome right now and it's two
years away. I think that's part of the muddling of this conversation.
I think that's a part of all the conversations we've been having
politically for on the left and the right. We just can't have
honest conversations with anybody about anything. And that's
part of the problem. Anyway,
>> I don't think that it's good framing for us to apologize
for liberal commentators who are all pretty much we all know
that they're pretty much discussed about the same thing. We all
know that. And for Adam to hear it like apologize be like it's
getting muddled. No, the people who are doing the muddle apology
or just an or describing what's happen it's assuming responsibility
when the muddling is being done by these tanky loser who can't
answer a question and keep trying to change. >> How do
they apologize? just by by acknowledging it >> because
acknowledging that it's >> He's pretending as though the
fault is. >> Okay, never mind. The guy doesn't realize
it's a bit >> the messaging liberals. >> Wait, can
you
>> Oh, yes, absolutely. I absolutely can. Yes, 100%. >> Look
at how he says this. >> Coming up. So, I'm not asking you
to like jump up and down for Gavin Newsome. However, I do want
to talk about your response to
>> Dude, how
bro How are these your guys? These are like your best guys.
This is like your best guy right now,
bro. If I'm pretty sure if if Substance got a straight got on
a stream, if Simply Substance got on a stream right now and looked
this,
I I don't think I could recover from that. Okay, I just couldn't
I couldn't actually recover from that. That would be rough. >> That
would be really rough, man. >> I do have some thoughts
and I think I can bring a pretty good faith version of what a
lot of people on Twitter are trying to say, but kind of >> they're
trying to say it, right? Right. As in they're failing. They're
they're trying to say it, but they're not doing a good job of
it. >> Okay. Yeah. And then look in >> and then it's
getting muddled. No. No. Absolutely. No. He's saying liberals
are like trying to explain something to you as though they're
doing a bad job of it. That's obviously what he's saying.
>> No. You're off. >> You don't agree with that.
>> Your radar is off. >> What do you think he's What
do you think he's saying there? That it's just like an honest
mistake. >> Trying to accurately describe the situation
that's happening on Twitter over the past week. >> You
don't think it's by and large tanky trying to deflect and change
the subject? You you think it's liberals were not being accurate
and calibrated? No, I think everyone is probably being a little
bit wacky, but I do think the Yankees are worse, obviously. But
>> Okay, so why not mention that? So why not mention that?
>> Because again, he's in the very beginning of the conversation.
He said he's trying to come into it in good
Good faith. One part about being good faith is actually coming
in willing to have a conversation. >> Wait, why would you
ever be good faith to Hassan when he has showed consistently
he'll just lie. He'll lie about his positions. There's no point
being good faith about his arguments. >> Because some people
are just built to yell at Hassan all day every day and treat
him like a dog. other people are better suited to go in and have
conversations like this where maybe Adam is able to get a couple
people who are watching Hassan. They'll watch this whole conversation.
See how you know
>> Adam built diff little bro Adam built diff if you were
like Adam or Destiny Pisco you could have conversations with
leftists but actually you're too naive and nice Pisco you know
the things Pisco is known for being like way too nice to people
way too forgiving of people you know that that kind of thing.
Yeah Pisco Pisco is just too nice to talk to these leftists.
I I'm pretty sure that Hassan was in this during this debate.
You >> think Assan Hassan getting a from Adam Mockler and
Adam being super nice is going to win him over respect and fans.
No, they think you're weak. Obviously, >> again, the comment
like you said, you said you haven't watched this, so how are
you saying that? >> Well, I suspected just based on the
introduction here. >> And okay, >> regarding criticism
of the Democratic party, probably where the Democratic Party
needs to go will agree a lot. >> He says he agrees with
a lot of Hassan's criticism of Democrats. He has the most unhinged
criticism of Democrats and he agrees with Han on where Democrats
need to go. You okay with that? >> Are you okay with that?
>> Dumb comment. Yeah, that was a dumb >> No, that
that's like up, right? >> Calm down, dude. This is >> Wait,
wait. What do you mean calm down? >> You're doing a good
job. Listen, I know you're having fun like doing this, but >> we
just If you admit it, it would be much better. >> Wait,
wait, wait. Hang on, hang on a second. No, I just want to make
sure that we understand what he just said. He just said, "I agree
with a lot of your criticism." Yeah. Yeah. Make sure. Just make
sure. ever. I do want to talk about your response to Jennifer
Welch on that podcast because I do have some thoughts and I think
I can bring a pretty good faith version of what a lot of people
on Twitter are trying to say but kind of getting muddled in.
But um yeah, we're going to agree on a lot regarding criticism
of the Democratic party where the Democratic party needs to go.
We'll agree on the Democratic party.
>> No, but he's saying he'll agree with >> Hassan's
criticism of the Democrats. That's unhinged. >> He's sweeping
so hard. >> Wait, Hassan? No, it's bad faith. Hassan doesn't
want the Democratic party to do well. He's a sabotur. He works
for MAGA. Why would you agree with Hassan's criticism of the
Democratic party and where it needs to go? Wait, do you not agree
with that? Why are you laughing? >> No, I I think that
he can have disagreements and those disagreements can actually
line up with reality. Let's say that he says that Joe Biden should
have stepped out earlier. >> I would agree with that. >> Do
you understand you understand why they wanted Joe Biden to step
out, >> Yeah. So they can >> It's cuz they called
him genocide Joe. It's cuz they called him genocide Joe,
>> And why else would he want that? What else was wrong
with him? >> Well, no. That that's they would No, they
don't care about winning. They just want their own candidates
in installed and they don't give a they don't give a [__]
about >> what else is wrong with Biden in the leadup to
the election. >> Well, obviously [clears throat] they'll
agree he's old, but that's just the way to get him to drop out
because of Gaza. If you were old and like
trying to focus in on the other thing, so like why would you
agree?
>> Dude, it's actually way better than I expected. Okay.
Okay. I'm seeing it. I'm seeing it. Oh my goodness.
It's actually even better than I expected cuz he's like basically
this guy's to go No, no, no, no. And the funny thing is is he's
not really even doing like a caricature. Like he's basically
just quoting
while
sounding serious. He's more or less just quoting. Okay.
>> Biden stepping out. Now the reason they want to step
out could be two different things. But they both agree that he
should have stepped down earlier. And that maybe either either
would in Adam's mind give Kamla a better chance of winning or
in Hassan's mind maybe I don't know Bernie Sanders or AOC have
a better chance. >> This is so ultra charitable. You would
never give this good faith to someone like Hutch.
to someone like Hutch. You would never be this good faith to
someone like Hutch.
>> This guy's going back and forth between realizing it's
a bit and then he like thinks Pisco is not doing the bit anymore
and then he gets confused when Pisco is still doing the bit.
He like somehow thinks Pisco is like falling out of the bit and
he answers seriously
like he just answered seriously,
right? >> I've never spoken to Hutch, but I would probably
be good faith to most. >> No, not like this. You are going
you are contorting so hard to be nice to Hassan and to gain his
crisis.
>> Okay, dude. Go ahead. >> Well, no. I'm just saying
it's not just even if I were to grant that backwards facing there's
good criticisms. He says I agree with you probably on where the
party needs to go. That's crazy.
>> You agree? Isn't that crazy? >> I think we should
Why don't we listen? >> No, wait. I I just want to just
stop. >> Wait, I just want to make sure we're having a
real conversation. I don't even know if this is a conversation
that this is like Are we actually having uh next? Yeah, you can.
>> Okay. Yeah. So, so like so I just want to know that
we're having conversation. Do you agree that this is like a crazy
thing to say?
>> No, not not in >> not in context. Okay. >> Not
in the context of this conversation, especially where we are
in the conversation right now. >> Party as well, but I
think there's criticisms of the way that you you approach that
question or the way that you talk about this. But >> yeah.
Yeah. If you want if you want to >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> kind
of getting muddled in. But um yeah, we're going to agree on a
lot regarding criticism of the Democratic party. Probably where
the Democratic party needs to go will agree a lot. I'm very disappointed
with the Democratic party as well.
>> You're right. There's a lot of hiding of the really
stupid rationale that they don't say the common sense thing is
like I you could tell already. They'll say things like yeah you
uh you don't get it. I don't I'm not going to explain criticisms
that question. >> I don't know what to do for you man.
If you don't get it by now then I guess you just like actually
don't understand >> the way you talk about this. But >> yeah.
Yeah. If you want if you want to know what my position I feel
like >> you mean maybe you should just delete your channel
if you don't get it yet. If you don't get it >> at the
very end there he said he disagrees with a lot of the things
he's having in the conversation. I I mean I I I get that, but
I think when you start by sort of having the common ground as
though we're part of the same side, it kind of detracts a little
bit >> doing that or just being like a g like a you know
being nice to somebody you're talking to to for the first time.
>> I think he's creating a >> like how you would
be nice like you had like cordial conversations with Rob >> Well,
that's I think different. I think my audience you think my audience
seriously is in any danger of falling to Rob No's wits. My audience
knows that when I have a convers he's actually doing a really
good job. He's actually doing the state machine. He's like thought
about this, like figured out how he would argue this and then
like I feel I feel like he's got a legal pad somewhere where
he's like written down how they're arguing this out so he can
figure out how to like argue back against it, right? And he probably
just knows the other side of this dialogue
>> Oh, dude, that's very funny. What time is the game at?
What time is it? Or if I have a conversation with like Myron
Games or something, my audience knows that that's not good. Oh,
it's different. Obviously, >> does your audience not know?
>> Are you really trying to compare? Are you really trying
to compare Rob No? No, I'm just saying that you can have cordial
conversations. You're really trying to >> No, I'm trying
to say that you can have cordial conversations with people you
disagree vehemently with. >> Well, if you know your audience
isn't gonna be [__] captured by Tanky Fox.
>> Do you think that for your audience? >> Obviously
not because I guard them against them by criticizing people like
>> Eastern [__] >> Okay. But before this,
>> [__] me. I don't know. Maybe >> I
You think I support communism orism or Marxist Londonism? >> No.
No. But I I like this uh your your um your attitude and your
demeanor now is different. This is the first time I think you've
come into a stream, at least the one that I've caught, where
you've been like this, been this hard.
>> I'm not going to answer that cuz it's
>> This hard on communists.
>> I'm going way harder than mocker as you agree that,
right? Like before I said that was hard, but this is the hardest
you've ever gone.
>> Dude, I Dude, it's so painful. It's so painful. That's
so painful. >> Like you're like >> I'm I'm really
encouraged by this Pisco. You seem like you're taking this really
seriously now and I'm so happy that you're on our side. You're
on the right side. You got the right mentality, bro.
Bro, [groaning] this is tough, man. This is tough,
>> Huh? Well, I don't know that I'm putting on a show.
I think that I'm just doing what any good liberal would do, which
is to call out people who are creating a permission structure
to interact with an illiberal person who fundamentally wants
to destroy liberal democracy. And that's what Adam is doing.
He's he's creating a permission structure for that. >> Okay.
But also, but again, so I guess the only reason you do that with
right-wing people is because you don't you're not worried. >> Of
course, obviously. Yes. Obviously. >> Okay. So, it's only
So, if if you were in without an audience, you talk, you would
say this conversation is fine. >> Yes. Because they're
there's no danger and my audience knows where I stand on Rob
No. They know that. And do you think there's danger for Mockler's
audience? >> Um, actually yes. Actually, yes. Actually,
yes. Obviously. >> Why do I think I think >> because
his audience is going to get the impression that Hassan is just
a little bit to the left of Adam Mockler when he's not. He's
something else. >> How do you know? Again, we're only we're
only for 30 40 seconds in. >> Well, I just assume that
that's how the conversation is going to go. >> Really?
Why? >> Because of how it started.
>> Zar, and I think you're already pretty familiar with
my positions. I know that like you you've probably heard me speak
on these issues for years and years at this point, but um my
primary goal, especially in the interim, especially in the short
term, is the defeat of fascism. I believe that the Republican
party is an illiberal party, a post- liberal party, whatever
you want to call it. And I think unlike uh the uh historic inception
of fascism as a revolutionary movement at a time when liberalism
was failing only 100 years ago, this time that we have two liberal
parties in America, like as a political theory, we have two liberal
parties, right? Like we say conservative, whatever, but like
technically the Republicans are also a liberal uh party. I warned
about this the firstction in this conversation. I think that
was one of the big things that Adam did wrong in this conversation
>> as well. I warned about uh I warned about the the protofascist
nature of Donald Trump. Um I thought that it was important to
make that distinction. I didn't say that Trump like season one
of Donald Trump was fully fascist, but season two of Donald Trump
is. And I think it's important to make that distinction as well
because like you can see the difference, right? Like it there
were a lot of there was a lot of naked corruption. A lot of things
that were going on in the first Trump administration, but the
second Trump administration has been so brazen, so obvious. And
it's not like they've hidden that reality at all, especially
when they were um when they were running uh to to become the
president, when they were running during the >> He's letting
him yap more. This is like when I talk to Counterpoints and it
just starts, right? And he just starts yapping. All of a sudden,
you [__] you fall asleep. He's talking about Warhammer
40k. >> Yeah. Um uh in the 2024 election season. So my
primary goal is to defeat that completely. And obviously I also
want to build socialism. >> Right now, do you agree that
Hassan has a skin suit on? >> 100%. Yeah, obviously. And
Adam is not exposing it. Instead, he's having a polite conversation
and letting Hassan skinw walk as though he is one of us when
he's not. >> So, I guess if Adam were to go on like hammer
in the same question three times in a row and Hassan obviously
didn't answer. He Hassan tried to do a skin suit dance and it
kind of like blows up in his face. You would consider that a
good strat by Adam, right? >> Well, I think that you need
to be super aggressive with these people so it's better than
the strat he's doing. Is it >> Every single person needs
to be aggressive. There aren't even methods of >> I think
I think largely yes. I I think we're at that point yet. >> I
don't think you believe that. I think I think largely yes. [laughter]
>> I I actually I actually do think that
>> to ostracize these people need to be like know that
they can't be around us at protest and I think that's great.
>> There's different ways you can do it. Like you can have
a guy >> they're not welcome Chad standing over top of
somebody yelling at them and then you can have the group of girls
who like laugh at that kid every single time and destroy his
self-esteem. Like there's different ways to bring people down.
Um, this is making it some people are better. This is making
Adam is that much >> it's like you're just listening to
somebody who's got like um
this person is like a populist in their soul. They like they're
like thinking without any experience in this field. They have
a better idea of how to do this than Pisco. They have a better
idea than people who have been operating in this field. They've
got a better idea than anybody who's got experience talking to
other people. Anything like that. I don't know what this guy
does. It seems like he's just like gonna take other people's
opinions and be like, "Pisco, this is how you This is actually
how this could work.
He doesn't
It's rough, man. It's just rough listening to
somebody who doesn't know what they're talking about come in
with this much confidence."
And I think they're like an older guy, too. Like I think this
guy's like 40. Like he's like 30, 40. Having this level of like
overconfidence when you're like a 20-year-old kind of makes sense.
when you're like that much older, you should have a good idea
that like you should have way less
you should have way less of that like weird overconfidence that
like um
I'm not saying he's it's I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with being old. I'm saying usually when you have experience in
the world, you calibrate your confidence to like in in a much
more rational way. You've learned that like oh when you're overconfident
how it sets you back and it just doesn't have that. It's very
weird to me. But like I don't know if Adam's much of like a hostile
guy. I don't think they ever seen him like that. >> Then
he shouldn't then he just shouldn't do these debates. Then he
just >> No, he can be able He can do it in his own different
way. There's other ways to put people down and make them look
>> You think you think it's Adam's goal to make look stupid?
>> Uh Pisco needs to ban this chatter. You can mog Pisco
by eating snacks on camera right now. Pisco needs to ban this
chatter immediately. It's an unhinged snarky chatter.
Unhinged snarky chatter right here. Okay. Very snarky chatter
over here. Ban this person immediately.
I have a feeling I have a feeling this
would laugh
when somebody brings up the skull sent to Ethan Klein. I have
a feeling that that's the kind of person this person is. Absolutely
disgusting. >> I don't think that shows up >> really.
Yeah. Yeah. >> I don't know. Maybe you're right. >> To
uh build a working- class movement. And I don't think these two
goals are at odds with one another. I think both historically,
by the way, if for some random reason the stream starts cutting
out, that's not my stream. If for if this were to happen sometime,
I don't know because I haven't seen it yet, but if this were
to start happen, don't worry. It's >> It will likely be
that I know for sure, but it was 99% be the other stream. >> Wait,
what? >> And also, >> I'm saying if it starts cutting
out, it will I haven't seen this yet, but if it were to, >> it
would be the stream. It wouldn't be my streaming to you. Does
that make sense? If it were to do that. >> Got it. Got
it. Got it. Got it. Sorry. Yeah. Took me a second. General, I
believe that uh the the evolution away from the liberal system
that we exist under that is that is now failing for the second
time around and and making way for fascism. The only solution
out of that is uh is to build a working-class based organized
socialist movement. Um but yeah, those are my two those are my
two main points. Um if I guess I want to ask you, do you think
it would be easier? Do you think it would be meaningfully easier
to build this working-class socialist based movement in a liberal
society or an illiberal >> Oh, historically speaking, most
likely an illiberal society. At least historically speaking,
socialist and communist movements have have >> So I think
that's good what Adam just did right there. I think it's good
that he got he got Hassan to admit that in order to for him to
get where he wants to go, we need to destroy liberalism. And
I think it's >> because insane. Okay. So I I would agree
that's good. If he is able to follow up and say that that's what
Hassan wants because unless he does that, then it seems like
all he's doing is getting Hassan to yap about history. But if
Hassan is able >> No, but that No,
>> no. I disagree. I think that Hassan realizing that that's
how you want to get to his end goal. That's a that is a step
that is necessary to get to social. >> He didn't say that.
He said he said what would be easier and he said historically
it would be illiberal. That's what he said. He hasn't said that
that's what Hassan would want. That's the necessary thing that
Adam the funny thing is if he well okay how about this if Hassan
doesn't give away to do it without
or without removing liberalism and getting into an illiberal
>> oh I forgot that the name Kosher Cathy is literally
yeah it's like loner box snark in and of itself. I forgot that.
Yeah I for >> society would you think that's good? All
right, let's see if he does. If he says that he wants liberalism
>> and that he is a good socialist, Adam needs to challenge
him on that. Like Hassan before has said that he supports >> uh
re-education camps. He has said before he's a Marxist List,
>> uh gun to you. Thank you for the five subs. You guys
keep donating and I'm like super not committed to serving for
the whole night, but thank you so much. I appreciate it. I appreciate
the app letting it go unrebuted. What preferences is liberal
communism very generous. Sorry. You guys have been very generous
tonight. I don't know how long I'm going to stream for. I just
feel like um I've streamed a lot in the recent past. I feel like
this month my streaming time is like way way way up. Although
maybe I took some nights off so maybe not as much up as I thought.
>> What he wants
>> What I will define as success is if he challenges Assan.
If Hassan says something like, "I would want liberalism." But
if he doesn't do that, then he's failed. Okay, let's just make
sure about that. >> Liberal society. >> Oh, historically
speaking, most likely an illiberal society. At least historically
speaking, socialist and communist movements have have unfortunately
only been successful. >> Unfortunately, did you hear that?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Because Hassan doesn't actually want to
get he lives too comfy of a life. That's why he said that. >> Wait,
I wouldn't be able to I won't be able to get my Gucci. >> Wait,
so do you think that Hassan I'm conf
It's so crazy. I'm so confused.
Does does Assan want to end liberalism because he's a Marist
or does he want to maintain it? He wants his Gucci back. >> He
understands that historically that is how you get there. >> But
which does he want? Does he want the end of liberalism? >> We
haven't gotten to that part of the conversation yet. >> No,
I'm asking you based on your >> I don't know. We haven't
gotten there yet. I got to listen to him talk. >> Wait,
why would you need to listen to him? He's lying. He just likes
to lie.
>> Why you Why are you laughing? >> Hit play.
>> The material conditions have worsened. I don't I don't
want that to happen, though. It could be >> Yeah, right.
He just said he doesn't want ill liberalism. >> Well, I
Yeah, he doesn't want it to happen again because then he won't
be able to charge his car. >> Wait, so you agree that he
doesn't want the end of liberalism? That he's a
>> No, I think he doesn't want to have to go through the
hard part to get to where he wants to go.
>> He's not willing to suffer achieve his end political
goal. >> Well, because maybe other people will
>> and he can motivate those people in a way. Yeah, that
can be seen as a threat. >> But you don't actually think
that he wants to tear down the liberal order because he thrives
in it. No, he would always be on the sidelines.
Interesting. [laughter] >> Then why is he concerned about
it getting worse?
Why is he concerned? Why are you saying it's getting worse for
him? He doesn't want to give things up. He's going to be on the
sidelines chilling anyway,
>> dude.
Move to another country and keep doing the thing. >> Got
it. >> An appropriate thing to move towards. I don't think
that that's good for people. I think it's very He thinks it's
bad to move from illiberalism. All right. Okay. Well, I guess
that's a good thing that Adam got him to say. >> Mhm. Yeah.
violent and very deadly. I don't want the material conditions
to
>> And you believe him? You think that he he doesn't want
the material conditions to deteriorate? >> Selfishly, yes.
>> Okay. But if you're asking me like honestly from a historical
perspective. Oh, no. >> I'm basically asking I'm basically
>> dude. Okay.
if Hassan gets the bit, he should actually react to this conversation.
This conversation is actually you have to be you have to be very
intelligent to understand this conversation. Not really. said
to be paying attention. This is like actually Oh, this is this
is actually brutal to watch as somebody who doesn't Oh, it's
just it's actually brutal to watch no matter what. It's just
brutal to watch, man. >> Just asking if >> Assan
might not Han might not get
like >> this would be very funny for him to >> But
it's not even about that. They're kind of standins. I don't even
want to concede who our nominees going to be two years ahead.
But I think it would be there would be a meaningful difference
in building a you know pro labor movement under a JD Vance presidency.
It would be much much harder versus a Gavin Newsome presidency.
I mean JD Vance his entire career has been uh has been trying
to step on top of workers. He wants to he project he endorsed
project 2025 which literally wants to bring >> he agrees
>> labor laws back to 1938. He's fundamentally illiberal
and doesn't want to let you organize. I mean like a lack of organization
is part of not living in a liberal society, right? They will
squash that. They will kill communists. They will kill socialists.
That's what they did in other fascist societies. They socialist
and communists. Meanwhile, Gavin Newsome, however insufficient
you may think he is, and this is not an endorsement of Gavin
Newsome. I'm just trying to illustrate my points of, you know,
the different realities we can enter. However insufficient you
think Davin Newsome is, he would allow for >> if this conversation
were happening in isolation, I would think this is like so awesome
from Adam, right? >> Mhm. Why? Why? What do you like about
>> Because if I knew that Hassan wasn't a bad faith loser,
>> I would really enjoy that Adam and him are like agreeing
on some base principles like liberalism, like that Vance is worse
than Newsome. I think those are all like very effective messages.
If I felt his audience weren't poisoned by Tanky and that he
himself weren't trying to embed himself to poison our movement,
then I would obviously take issue with this stain washing framing
and the sane washing permission structure that Adam is imposing
on all of us.
>> A really strong labor move allow for you guys to
>> I still like the way that Adam approaches conversation.
He could have done better at it, but I don't think I wouldn't
necessarily say that that me like what you just described automatically
makes it bad. Again, like I said, there there are many different
ways you can approach conversations. There are many different
ways you can clown on people. And Adam chose his own
>> or build bridges. I think he's building a bridge with
Assan. Do you agree?
>> Well, at the end of the conversation build a bridge,
if anything, if
a bridge for his audience to come over to Adam's >> Oh,
no. Because I suspect at the end of this conversation based on
>> Wait.
[clears throat] Oh, man.
Man, what am I thinking here? I just see there's a lot of people
doing work on Twitter right now in just the gayest ways
draw attention just on the um like I will actually like this
tweet right
>> Am I misunderstanding this? According to Pisco, Destiny
lied about Aaron being a communist. Have I entered the Twilight
Zone? I'm pretty sure this >> podcast a few
>> I'm pretty sure. Oh, did he post this? Oh, maybe he
posted this before Destiny and Pisco talked. Destiny literally
conceded to Pisco on this. Is it like literally a concession?
It's It's He lied about her being an ML
obviously
and then he tried to justify lying about her being an ML. Got
blown the out again. Good morning from Europe. Welcome Snowy.
I don't know how to say your name. I'm sorry. I apologize. >> Let's
follow up >> at the end and let's like get together in
LA. I assume that's what he'd say based on how it started. >> Maybe.
And that would be building a bridge, wouldn't it? If he did say
that. >> No, not necessarily. What if the next conversation
he comes in, he lulls Hassan in with a false sense of security
and then he comes in and and brings the hammer down. Wouldn't
that be cinema >> Yeah, but I just don't trust that he's
not just going to have another fest. >> Why not, man? He's
dude. He's on CNN. He's good. >> He's up there debating
professionals. He knows how to do it better than anyone. >> Maybe.
Maybe.
>> Listen, he is just a kid. But he's a >> He's a
kid, isn't he? 20. >> Uh, let's see how
I'm going to guess. Um, 22. It's going to be like 19. I'm going
to be even more depressed. My guy is
23 ream. [clears throat] >> Well, Price's right. I didn't
go over >> practically a toddler.
>> Yeah, right. He doesn't even have a fully developed
brain yet. >> Communicate with you guys. Do you >> first
of all, I don't even think you guys I think you're a part of
this as well. I don't you're not against like
>> here. Do you mind? Sorry. >> Sorry. He's like
socialist and communist. Meanwhile, Gavin Newsome, however insufficient
you may think he is, and this is not an endorsement of Gavin
Newsome. I'm just trying to illustrate my points of, you know,
the different realities we could enter. However insufficient
you think Gavin Newsome is, he would allow for a really strong
labor movement. He would allow for you guys to at least, you
know, organize and he would probably communicate with you guys.
>> First of all, I don't even think you guys I think you're
a part of this as well. I don't you're not against like organizing
labor movement. >> He says, "Yeah." >> Did you hear
what that just happened there? Wait, no. I don't want to go on.
>> Keep playing. >> Say you're a part of it, too.
>> He's expressing solidarity with Assad. You disagree?
>> How How could you possibly disagree that that wasn't
an expression of solidarity when Adam said yes to what Hassan
just >> What do you mean by like what was he agreeing in
solidarity to? to um the nature of um you know tamping down on
protest and labor rights different realities we can enter that's
what you think is okay I
I feel bad I am like
I'm like tired I I feel so bad for leaving but I think I am going
to call